Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. 60 days the papacy had given Martin Luther to recant, or else be damned as a heretic. Now, on the 10th of December, the time was up. That morning at nine o'clock, Luther walked through one of the three town gates to where a carrion pit lay. A large crowd had gathered there. One of Luther's colleagues from the university, a theologian named Johann Agricola, lit a fire. The spot was where the clothes of those who had died in the nearby hospital were burned.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。教皇给了马丁·路德60天时间忏悔，否则将被定为异端。现在，到了12月10日，期限已到。那天早上九点，路德穿过三座城镇大门之一，来到一个腐尸坑旁。一大群人聚集在那里。路德的一位大学同事，一位名叫约翰·阿格里科拉的神学家，点燃了一堆火。这个地方正是焚烧附近医院死者衣物的地方。
But Agricola, rather than rags, used books as fuel. All that morning he and Luther had been ransacking libraries for collections of canon lore. Had the two men been able to find a volume of Aquinas, they would have burned that as well. Their kindling, though, proved sufficient. The fire began to blaze. Agricola continued to feed books into the flames. Then Luther stepped out from the crowd. He was trembling. He held up the papal decree that had condemned his teachings. Because you have confounded the truth of God, he said in a ringing voice, today the Lord confounds you into the fire with you. He dropped the decree into the flames.
但阿格里科拉用的不是破布，而是书籍作为燃料。那天整个上午，他和路德一直在图书馆里搜寻教会法典的藏书。如果这两人能找到一本阿奎那的著作，他们也会把它烧掉。不过，他们的引火物已经足够了。火势开始熊熊燃烧。阿格里科拉不断地往火里扔书。这时，路德从人群中走了出来。他在颤抖。他举起那份谴责他教义的教皇敕令。他用洪亮的声音说道：“因为你混淆了上帝的真理，今天主也要混淆你，让你进入火中。”他将敕令扔进了火焰。
The parchment blackened and curled and turned to smoke. As Luther turned and walked back through the city gate, ashes skittered and swirled on the winter breeze. So that was Dan Brown. That was Tom Holland. So that was Dan Brown. That was Tom Holland. So rude. In Dominion, which is your magisterial book about the history of Christianity and how it has shaped the Western world, and indeed the entire world, Tom,
羊皮纸变黑、卷曲，化为烟雾。当路德转身穿过城门走回时，灰烬在冬日的微风中飞舞盘旋。那是丹·布朗。那是汤姆·霍兰德。那是丹·布朗。那是汤姆·霍兰德。真没礼貌。汤姆，在你的权威著作《多米尼恩》（Dominion）中，你讲述了基督教的历史，以及它如何塑造了西方世界，乃至整个世界，
I think it's fair to say. And this is an amazing set piece moment. So we are now in episode three of this series about the human being who in the last five to 600 years has arguably shaped the Western world as much as any other, maybe more than any other. Martin Luther. He is burning a papal bull, a papal decree that was targeted at him. So this is open war with the papacy, Tom. It is. So this is ex surge domine, rise up, O Lord. And the Pope had issued it on the 15th of June, 1520, and had given Luther 60 days to recant or be excommunicated. And the 60 days are up.
我想说这是公平的。这是一个令人惊叹的重头戏时刻。我们现在进入了这个系列的第三集，讲述的是在过去五到六百年里，可以说塑造了西方世界，甚至可能比任何人都塑造得更多的人。马丁·路德。他正在焚烧一份教皇诏书，一份针对他的教皇敕令。所以，汤姆，这是与教皇的公开战争。确实如此。这是《主啊，起来吧》（Exsurge Domine）。教皇于1520年6月15日发布了它，并给了路德60天时间忏悔，否则将被逐出教会。而60天期限已到。
And Luther's response to this deadline is as written in that magisterial praise beautiful and uh the bull is specifically censoring 41 propositions that luther has put forward and one of those propositions dominic is that it's wrong to burn heretics and so the danger of death yeah the fact that Luther, by directly taking on the papacy like this, you know, I mean, it's an exceedingly dangerous thing to do. This is life and death. Yes. And this is happening in Wittenberg, the capital of Frederick, the Elector of Saxony.
路德对这个最后期限的回应，正如那部权威著作中所写的那样，非常精彩。呃，这份诏书特别审查了路德提出的41条主张，其中一条主张，多米尼克，是说焚烧异端分子是错误的。所以，死亡的危险，是的，事实上，路德通过这样直接对抗教皇，你知道，我的意思是，这是一件极其危险的事情。这是生死攸关的。是的。而这一切都发生在弗雷德里克，萨克森选帝侯的首都维滕贝格。
And Luther is a professor at the university. So Frederick has every stake in kind of backing him. And three years have passed since that great and celebrated act of defiance that we ended episode two with. Hammering the theses or not on the walls of the church or churches. Yes, onto the doors of the church. And in those three years, Luther has precipitated a crisis on a scale that Latin Christendom has never witnessed before, at least not since the 11th century. And the features of the crisis, they're kind of threefold really. So it's about the church essentially asserting its authority, the medieval church, the Roman church, whatever you want to call it. So back in 1517, the whole reason why these indulgences are being issued is because the church is manifesting its assumption that Christians can earn their way out of purgatory through buying them or through a whole host doing good works, pilgrimages, whatever.
路德是大学教授。所以弗雷德里克有充分的理由支持他。距离我们第二集结尾提到的那个伟大而著名的反抗行为已经过去了三年。把论文钉在教堂或教堂的墙上，或者没有钉。是的，钉在教堂的门上。在那三年里，路德引发了一场拉丁基督教世界从未见过的规模的危机，至少自11世纪以来从未有过。这场危机的特征实际上是三重性的。所以，这本质上是关于教会维护其权威，中世纪教会，罗马教会，无论你怎么称呼它。回到1517年，发行这些赎罪券的全部原因是因为教会表现出一种假设，即基督徒可以通过购买赎罪券，或者通过做善事、朝圣等一系列行为，来赚取通往炼狱之外的道路。
This idea that there is a kind of spiritual capital that Christians can draw on to get themselves out of purgatory and get to heaven sooner. And of course, in 1520, the assumption is that the church has the right to eradicate heresy. This is why the Pope has issued the bull. Can I ask a quick question, Tom? Yeah. Lots of people will be thinking this. Why is it called a bull? It's called a bull, which is obviously a papal bull. That's very Protestant. But it's a bullalla it's a kind of a seal that stamps the the text of it okay fine i've always wondered and uh you know and the church has been doing this for a long time so one of the phrases that is used in this papal bull that's targeting luther is the same phrase that people who listen to our episode on the albigensian crusades may
这种想法认为，基督徒可以利用一种精神资本，让自己更快地离开炼狱并进入天堂。当然，在1520年，人们认为教会拥有根除异端的权利。这就是教皇发布诏书的原因。汤姆，我可以问个简单的问题吗？可以。很多人会想这个问题。为什么它被称为“诏书”（Bull）？它被称为“Bull”，显然是教皇诏书（Papal Bull）。这非常新教。但它是一个“bullalla”，这是一种盖在文本上的印章。好吧，我一直很好奇。而且，你知道，教会长期以来一直这样做。所以，这份针对路德的教皇诏书中使用的短语之一，与听过我们关于阿尔比派十字军那一集的人可能
remember yeah the phrase about the little foxes seeking to destroy the vineyard, exactly the same phrase. And Tom, just to remind people, Luther hammered up these theses or nailed them up or didn't, depending on your view, because he was outraged because a bloke was going around, a kind of carnival-esque monk, was going around selling indulgences to raise money for the rebuilding of St. Peter's Basilica in Rome. And Luther just thought this was disgraceful. Yeah. And it turns out to be even worse because actually loads of the money is going to a bank that has given money to an underage bishop who wanted to become archbishop. So it's all fabulously corrupt. So that's one aspect of it. The church basically
记得的短语一样，是的，关于“寻找破坏葡萄园的小狐狸”的短语，完全一样的短语。汤姆，提醒一下大家，路德把这些论文钉在墙上，或者钉上去，或者没有，取决于你的看法，因为他很愤怒，因为一个家伙到处走，一个类似狂欢节的僧侣，到处兜售赎罪券，为重建罗马圣彼得大教堂筹集资金。路德只是觉得这很丢脸。是的。结果更糟糕，因为实际上大量的钱流向了一家银行，这家银行给了一个想成为大主教的未成年主教钱。所以这一切都极其腐败。所以这是其中的一个方面。教会基本上
trying to put the lid on this kind of bubbling rebellion. And the second thread, of course, is Luther defying really fundamental teachings of the church. So in 1517, when he's attacking indulgences, he is also attacking the entire dogma that sinners can basically earn their way out of purgatory, that sinners have agency in getting rid of the penalty for their own sins. And that then leads him on to question the leading royal claim by the papacy and indeed, actually, the entire clergy. So he's starting to move towards a position that the clergy have no particular status. And so much of this comes from Luther saying he's been the professor of Bible studies
试图压制这种冒泡的叛乱。当然，第二条线索是路德挑战了教会真正根本的教义。所以，在1517年，当他攻击赎罪券时，他也在攻击整个教条，即罪人基本上可以赚取通往炼狱之外的道路，即罪人在消除自己罪孽的惩罚方面拥有代理权。这随后引导他质疑教皇，甚至实际上是整个神职人员的最高皇权。所以他开始转向一种立场，即神职人员没有任何特殊的地位。而这一切很大程度上源于路德说他一直是圣经研究的教授
at the university in Wittenberg. And so much of this is him saying, actually, do you know what? None of this is in the Bible. And if everything is meant to come from the Bible, this is all just tosh that has been dreamed up subsequently. Yeah. And so it's partly from his reading of the Bible and it's partly from his tugging on a thread and the whole carpet falls to pieces. So if you question a fundamental dogma, then you start to question the role of the papacy. Then you start to question the role of the clergy. And essentially Luther is coming to a much more democratic understanding of what it is to be a Christian, one in which
在维滕贝格大学。而这一切很大程度上是他说的，实际上，你知道吗？这些在圣经里都没有。如果一切都应该来自圣经，那么这一切都只是后来编造出来的废话。是的。所以这部分源于他对圣经的阅读，部分源于他拉动了一根线，整个地毯就散架了。所以如果你质疑一个根本的教条，那么你就开始质疑教皇的角色。然后你开始质疑神职人员的角色。本质上，路德正在走向一种更民主的基督教理解，在这种理解中，
the division between the clergy and the laity is being erased. He says, every true Christian, whether living or dead, has a part in all the blessings of Christ and the church. Is he thinking he's getting back to the early Christians? Yes. Like the Acts of the Apostles kind of Christians? Yeah. He's starting to construct an understanding of Christian history, which is radically opposed to the traditional one. So he is essentially saying that you have the early church and then it all goes wrong.
神职人员和平信徒之间的界限正在被抹去。他说，每一个真正的基督徒，无论生前还是死后，都在基督和教会的所有祝福中占有一份。他是在想他正在回到早期的基督徒那里吗？是的。像《使徒行传》那样的基督徒？是的。他开始构建一种基督教历史的理解，这与传统的理解截然相反。所以他本质上是在说，你有早期教会，然后一切都出错了。
And he is moving towards a position in which the papacy is the whore of Babylon, as described in the book of Revelation. And therefore, you know, a thousand years and more, it's been corrupting and polluting the pure teachings of Christ, which is obviously a very radical revision. It's not going to go down well with the Pope. It's not going to go down well, as we see, because he issues his bull. But the third aspect of what is making this a crisis is that Luther is an absolute master of self-promotion. And this is really unexpected. I mean, he's a professor in an obscure university, but he just kind of lights the touch paper.
他正在走向一个立场，即教皇是《启示录》中所描述的巴比伦淫妇。因此，你知道，一千多年来，它一直在腐蚀和污染基督的纯洁教义，这显然是一个非常激进的修正。这在教皇那里不会受欢迎。正如我们所见，这不会受欢迎，因为他发布了他的诏书。但使这成为危机的第三个方面是，路德是自我推销的绝对大师。这真的很出人意料。我的意思是，他是一所默默无闻的大学的教授，但他只是点燃了导火索。
And his mastery, particularly of printing, which we talked about in the previous episode, I mean, printing has been around for about a century, but he turns out to be absolutely suited to a kind of social media revolution. I mean, so Alec Ryrie, the great historian of Protestantism, he says he turns out to have a kind of raw Trumpian brilliance at German language polemic. And I think that people have been buying printed matter, but Luther makes it exciting. And so they get into the habit of buying it and perhaps kind of reading it out to people who can't read and so on. And so it's Luther really who generates the market for buying printed matter in a way that no one had done previously.
他对印刷术的掌握，特别是我们在上一集谈到的，我的意思是，印刷术已经存在了一个世纪左右，但他证明自己绝对适合一种社交媒体革命。我的意思是，亚历克·赖里（Alec Ryrie），伟大的新教历史学家，他说他证明自己在德语论战方面有一种原始的特朗普式的才华。我认为人们一直在购买印刷品，但路德让它变得令人兴奋。于是他们养成了购买它的习惯，也许还会读给那些不识字的人听，等等。所以，确实是路德以一种前所未有的方式创造了购买印刷品的市场。
And you know your Trumpian analogy. There's a kind of populist side to Luther's rhetoric, he's brilliant at describing things in very aggressive, scatological, sometimes funny, raw, kind of earthy terms in a way that maybe virtually no other theologians can do. So he can reach people who other people can't reach? Yes, absolutely. And the other thing that he does is that he's very, very good at staging a public event. So the burning of the bull in 1520, it's a deliberately dramatic thing. This is not what heretics do. Heretics who are condemned, they hide. They don't publicly defy the Pope because that would be mad. But Luther can do it because Frederick is guarding
你知道你的特朗普类比。路德的修辞有一种民粹主义的一面，他非常擅长以一种非常激进、粗俗、有时有趣、原始、接地气的方式来描述事物，这是几乎没有其他神学家能做到的。所以他能接触到其他人接触不到的人？是的，绝对可以。他做的另一件事是，他非常非常擅长策划公共活动。所以1520年焚烧诏书，这是一件刻意戏剧化的事情。这不是异端分子会做的事。被谴责的异端分子会躲起来。他们不会公开反抗教皇，因为那会是疯了。但路德可以这样做，因为弗雷德里克在保护
his back. But he's staging a kind of festival of defiance. And in the wake of the burning of the bull, he has got all his students behind him. The students are rallying to him. The day after the burning of the bull in Wittenberg, students build an enormous float and they festoon it with parodies of papal bulls and decrees and so on. They drive it around the town and then they burn the whole lot. One of them has dressed up as a pope in the papal tiara and he then toss one of them has dressed up as a Pope in a kind of, you know, the papal tiara, and he then tosses his tiara into the fire. So this is a kind of great festival of defiance and it's fun. Okay. So why are people doing that? Because
他的后背。但他正在策划一场反抗的节日。在焚烧诏书之后，他所有的学生都支持他。学生们正在团结在他周围。在维滕贝格焚烧诏书的第二天，学生们建造了一个巨大的花车，并用教皇诏书和法令的模仿品等装饰它。他们把它开遍全城，然后把整堆东西烧掉。其中一个人打扮成教皇，戴着教皇三重冠，然后他扔掉了一个人打扮成教皇，戴着某种，你知道，教皇三重冠，然后他把他的三重冠扔进了火里。所以这是一场伟大的反抗节日，而且很有趣。好吧。那么人们为什么要那样做呢？因为
what Luther is saying is very scandalous. So there are two possibilities there that either the students kind of are converted to Luther's way of thinking, maybe because he's such a brilliant teacher, or maybe because there was always a latent audience for that message, or are they just doing it because it's fun? I think both. Okay. And I think that, I mean, I guess we are so prone to not thinking that statements on Christian doctrine are exciting. Yeah. I mean, it's not the kind of thing that enthuses people by and large today, but back then it is the most thrilling thing you can do. And I mean, you just have to look at the sense of excitement that powers, I don't know, the pushing of doctrines that are offensive to conservatives today, say on social media. Yeah, of course.
路德所说的话非常令人震惊。所以那里有两种可能性，要么学生们被路德的思维方式所转化，也许是因为他是一位如此出色的老师，或者也许是因为那个信息一直有一个潜在的受众，或者他们只是因为好玩才这样做？我认为两者都有。好吧。而且我认为，我的意思是，我猜我们太倾向于不认为基督教教义的声明是令人兴奋的了。是的。我的意思是，这在今天并不是那种能让人们热血沸腾的事情，但在当时，这是你能做的最令人兴奋的事情。而且，我的意思是，你只需要看看那种推动，我不知道，推动今天保守派感到冒犯的教义的兴奋感，比如在社交媒体上。是的，当然。
I mean, people love it. They do. And likewise, conservatives quite enjoy kind of punching back. Exactly. Do you know what I was thinking about? I was thinking about 2020, the surge in people like attacking statues and stuff after the death of George Floyd. Yes, exactly. Some people are there because they really believe in the cause.
我的意思是，人们喜欢它。他们确实喜欢。同样，保守派也相当喜欢反击。完全正确。你知道我在想什么吗？我在想2020年，乔治·弗洛伊德死后，人们攻击雕像等行为的激增。是的，完全正确。有些人去那里是因为他们真的相信这个事业。
Some people are there because it's a laugh. They want to get out. The carnival-esque side of protest, the intoxication of it. Yeah, and I think that that is exactly right, because in the long run, statues will be toppled. Icons will be toppled in due course. And for reasons that are exactly analogous to the toppling of statues of slavers or whatever, that they are seen to be sinful. And a public display of your godliness is as exciting in the 21st century as it was in the 16th century. So it all goes back to Luther, basically. So today I think we should
有些人去那里是因为这很有趣。他们想出去。抗议的狂欢节一面，那种陶醉感。是的，我认为这完全正确，因为从长远来看，雕像会被推倒。偶像迟早会被推倒。其原因与推倒奴隶主雕像等完全类似，因为它们被视为是有罪的。在21世纪，公开展示你的虔诚和在16世纪一样令人兴奋。所以这一切基本上都回到了路德身上。所以今天我认为我们应该
look at how we get from Luther banging up the theses, if that's what he does, to him being excommunicated. And what happens in the wake of the 95 theses going up is that he has them printed in German as well as Latin and these start to hit the bookstalls in the new year of 1518 and they are produced by presses across the entire empire so the whole of what is now Germany and indeed Switzerland and in what will be the Netherlands as well. And because the theses are sharp, they're understandable, they're often quite witty, people can understand them. And they kind of really enjoy reading up. It kind of gives them a frisson, you know, almost a kind of the shiver of blasphemy about them. And to remind people, an important point,
看看我们是如何从路德钉上论文（如果那是他所做的话）到他被逐出教会的。在95条论纲发布之后，发生的事情是他让人把它们印成德语和拉丁语，这些在1518年新年开始出现在书摊上，它们是由整个帝国的印刷机生产的，所以整个现在的德国，甚至瑞士，以及未来的荷兰也是如此。因为这些论纲尖锐、易懂，而且通常相当机智，人们可以理解它们。他们真的很喜欢阅读。这给了他们一种战栗，你知道，几乎是一种亵渎的快感。提醒大家，一个重要的点，
the empire is a very strange, fragmented patchwork. So the imperial authority to deal with this necessarily is limited and depends upon local rulers, doesn't it? And that will be really important in Luther's story. Right. And in particular, the emperor is quite ill. And that means very likely there's going to be an imperial election very soon. And that, of course, gives an enormous power to Frederick, Luther's protector. It's one of only seven electors. Yeah, exactly. But even so, the church has no option but to respond to Luther's challenge. And this is partly because it seems that the sale of indulgences really starts to fall off in the wake of Luther's attack. But it's also because Luther has sent a copy to Albrecht,
帝国是一个非常奇怪、支离破碎的拼凑体。所以处理这个问题的帝国权威必然是有限的，并且依赖于地方统治者，不是吗？这在路德的故事中将非常重要。是的。特别是，皇帝病得很重。这意味着很可能很快就会有一次帝国选举。当然，这给了路德的保护者弗雷德里克巨大的权力。他只是七位选帝侯之一。是的，完全正确。但即便如此，教会除了回应路德的挑战别无选择。这部分是因为赎罪券的销售在路德攻击之后确实开始下降。但这也是因为路德给阿尔布雷希特寄了一份副本，
the Archbishop of Mainz, who is the guy, basically, who's caused the whole problem. Yeah, extraordinary that he sent it to the very person. Yeah, yes. It's like someone tagging you into a social media thing, exposing you or something, right? Yeah. And so Albrecht then sends it to Rome to get a kind of ruling, you know, in the centre of things. And the tradition is that the Pope doesn't recognize, you know, that it's a crisis at all. He just thinks it's a load of monks squabbling.
美因茨大主教，基本上就是那个导致整个问题的人。是的，他寄给当事人真是太不可思议了。是的。这就像有人在社交媒体上艾特你，揭露你什么的，对吧？是的。于是阿尔布雷希特随后把它寄到罗马，想在事情的中心得到一个裁决。传统是教皇根本不承认这是一个危机。他只是认为这是一群僧侣在争吵。
And it's kind of, you know, the lordly tone of a politician in 2010 turning his nose up at Twitter. Right. Saying it doesn't matter. It's unimportant. Nothing on this matters. Yeah. Meanwhile, back in Germany,
这有点像，你知道，2010年一位政客对推特嗤之以鼻的傲慢语气。对吧。说这无关紧要。这不重要。这根本不重要。是的。与此同时，回到德国，
they definitely have a sense of crisis so the dominicans give tetzel the guy who's been flogging the indulgences an honorary doctorate so that he can take on luther as an equal because of course luther has a doctorate he's a doctor yeah and tetzel is boasting that within three weeks of his getting his doctorate he will have luther in the flames and there's no question that Luther is in danger, but because he has the backing of Frederick, basically he's safe. And he also has the backing of, you know, we talked about the students, the students are already rallying behind him. They get hold of Tetzel's repudiation of Luther and burn it. So this is happening very, very early on. And it's interesting that book burning will be a feature of the Reformation.
他们确实有一种危机感，所以多米尼加人授予特策尔（那个一直在兜售赎罪券的家伙）荣誉博士学位，这样他就可以作为平等的人对抗路德，因为路德当然有博士学位，他是一位博士。是的，特策尔吹嘘说，在他获得博士学位后的三周内，他就会让路德进入火中。毫无疑问，路德处于危险之中，但因为他有弗雷德里克的支持，基本上他是安全的。他还有，你知道，我们谈到的学生们的支持，学生们已经团结在他身后。他们拿到了特策尔对路德的反驳书并烧掉了它。所以这在很早的时候就发生了。有趣的是，焚书将成为宗教改革的一个特征。
It actually begins with the reformers. It's not the papacy that is the first to burn books. Yeah, that is interesting. And it's interesting that it's students burning books. I mean, remember when we did the Nazi series and we talked about how Nazi book burnings are driven by students and their lecturers, not by people against the students' wishes. Well, and again, I mean, I think that you just have to look at the world today to realise that students quite enjoy, if not burning books, then having them banned. There is a kind of,
它实际上始于改革者。并不是教皇最先焚书。是的，这很有趣。而且有趣的是，是学生们在焚书。我的意思是，记得当我们做纳粹系列时，我们谈到纳粹焚书是如何由学生和他们的讲师推动的，而不是违背学生意愿的人。好吧，再说一次，我的意思是，我认为你只需要看看今天的世界就会意识到，学生们相当喜欢，如果不是焚书，那么就是禁止它们。有一种，
you know, an excitement in it, tearing down traditional structures and so on. And he also has the backing of growing numbers of the faculty in Wittenberg. So two particular will play key roles in his story. So one is the professor of theology, who's also the chancellor of the university. He's a guy called Andreas von Karlstadt. Yeah. And he had actually given Luther his doctorate, even though he's actually three years younger than Luther. And there's a much younger scholar who's the professor of Greek, Philip Melanchthon, who's only 21 so quite
你知道，其中的兴奋感，推倒传统结构等等。他还得到了维滕贝格越来越多的教员的支持。所以两个人将在他的故事中扮演关键角色。一个是神学教授，他也是大学校长。他叫安德烈亚斯·冯·卡尔施塔特。是的。他实际上给了路德博士学位，尽管他实际上比路德小三岁。还有一位年轻得多的学者，希腊语教授菲利普·梅兰希通，他只有21岁，所以相当
enoch powell he is like enoch powell does he speak like enoch powell no are you gonna do him in your birmingham accent no i'm not i'm not he'd renamed himself he did his name is actually schwarzer which means black earth and black earth has been translated into greek yeah and this is this is very much the kind of jape that professors at Wittenberg like to get up to. Does that count as a jape? Is that not just a terrible affectation? So Luther does it as well. So Luther's name is actually Luder.
伊诺克·鲍威尔，他就像伊诺克·鲍威尔，他说话像伊诺克·鲍威尔吗？不，你要用你的伯明翰口音模仿他吗？不，我不会，我不会。他给自己改了名字。他确实改了。他的名字实际上是施瓦泽（Schwarzer），意思是“黑土”，而“黑土”被翻译成了希腊语。是的，这非常像维滕贝格的教授们喜欢搞的那种恶作剧。那算恶作剧吗？那不是一种糟糕的矫揉造作吗？所以路德也这样做。所以路德的名字实际上是卢德（Luder）。
But he thinks this isn't good enough. So he calls himself Eleutherius, which in Greek means the freed one. Oh, come on. And he then makes more accessible as Luther. I think less of him now, Tom, knowing that. So Luther also is a kind of, it's a classicist's joke. Right. Great banter. Great banter. But Luther is making a serious point because he's saying he's freed, the freed one. So
但他认为这不够好。所以他称自己为Eleutherius，在希腊语中意思是“被释放的人”。哦，得了吧。然后他把它变得更容易接近，叫路德。汤姆，知道这一点后，我对他评价降低了。所以路德也是一种，这是一个古典学家的笑话。对吧。很棒的玩笑。很棒的玩笑。但路德提出了一个严肃的观点，因为他说他是被释放的，被释放的人。所以
what exactly has he been freed from? So he thinks presumably he's been freed from superstition, obscurantism, error, the darkness of not knowing the love of God. Is that it basically? Yes. So he gets summoned to a chapter meeting of the Augustinians. He's an Augustinian monk in April, 1518, and it's held in Heidelberg. So it's quite a long way. Again, we see his mastery of publicity he walks there right right so you know that that's really drawing attention to himself and he's treated as an absolute celebrity everywhere he goes he's kind of cheered and he gets to heidelberg and the local prince shows off you know his chapel and his castle and invites luther to dine with him so it's all tremendous
他到底从什么中被释放了？所以他大概认为他已经从迷信、蒙昧主义、错误、不知道上帝之爱的黑暗中被释放了。基本上就是这样吗？是的。所以他在1518年4月被传唤到奥古斯丁修会的一次分会会议。他是一位奥古斯丁僧侣，会议在海德堡举行。所以路程相当远。我们再次看到他掌握了宣传，他走着去那里。对，对，所以你知道，这真的引起了人们对他的注意。他走到哪里都被视为绝对的名人，他被欢呼，他到达海德堡，当地的王子炫耀他的教堂和城堡，并邀请路德与他共进晚餐。所以这一切都太棒了。
so tom is there a slight j slight Jordan Peterson side to all this? Yes, a little bit, I think. A celebrity professor who has said the unsayable, and who has suddenly... Do you remember how people first reported when Jordan Peterson was doing rallies and stuff? People would say, it's amazing that somebody who's basically talking about, what is it, some lobsters?
所以汤姆，这一切有一点乔丹·彼得森的一面吗？是的，我想有一点。一位说了不可说之事的名人教授，突然……你还记得人们最初是如何报道乔丹·彼得森举行集会什么的吗？人们会说，令人惊奇的是，有人基本上在谈论，那是什么，一些龙虾？
Jungian philosophy and stuff. Yeah, and Jungian philosophy. It's inspiring young people. What a remarkable thing. And it's the same... Exactly. If you think that he is saying things that in universities for a long time have been unsayable, Luther is doing something similar at Heidelberg. So he is now directly attacking the foundations of the theology that has prevailed in the Latin West for centuries and centuries. So as opposed to the idea that reason, as mediated through Aristotle, enables you to understand God, Luther says that reason is actually a whore. He says that philosophy is a delusion, that the only true Christian is a fool.
荣格哲学之类的。是的，还有荣格哲学。这激励了年轻人。多么了不起的事情。这同样……完全正确。如果你认为他正在说大学里长期以来不可说的事情，路德在海德堡也在做类似的事情。所以他现在直接攻击了几个世纪以来在拉丁西方占主导地位的神学基础。所以与通过亚里士多德调解的理性使你能够理解上帝的观点相反，路德说理性实际上是一个妓女。他说哲学是一种错觉，唯一的真基督徒是一个傻瓜。
He says out front, I believe it is impossible for the church to be reformed unless church law, so that's canon law, with its rules and decrees, scholastic theology, philosophy and logic, as they are now taught, are eradicated and replaced by other studies. Daily, I ask the Lord that the pure study of the Bible and the church fathers might be summoned back as soon as possible. So that is a bit like Jordan Peterson saying, gender studies, it's all woo-woo, post-colonial studies, all nonsense. Let's get rid of it all. Let's go back to studying Shakespeare or whatever. Or it's like people on the other side of that particular debate attacking their own disciplines. Yes. Isn't it? I mean, that's very popular and that's sort of
他直言不讳地说，我相信除非教会法（即教会法典，及其规则和法令）、经院神学、哲学和逻辑（正如现在所教的那样）被根除并被其他研究取代，否则教会是不可能改革的。我每天都祈求主，让圣经和教会教父的纯粹研究能尽快被召回。所以这有点像乔丹·彼得森说，性别研究，全是胡说八道，后殖民研究，全是废话。让我们摆脱这一切。让我们回到研究莎士比亚什么的。或者这就像那场特定辩论另一边的人攻击他们自己的学科。是的。不是吗？我的意思是，这非常受欢迎，而且那种
on the left as it were, the political spectrum is saying our whole discipline is colonial. It is tainted by prejudice. Let's get rid of it. Decolonize Anglo-Saxon studies or whatever. And people find that intoxicating. Right. And Luther is the wellspring of both those traditions. And that's what makes him so fascinating and important. So Luther is genuinely the place from which both those impulses come. Of course, he is in turn drawing on Augustine
在左翼，政治光谱上的人说我们的整个学科是殖民主义的。它被偏见玷污了。让我们摆脱它。去殖民化盎格鲁-撒克逊研究什么的。人们发现这令人陶醉。对吧。而路德是这两个传统的源头。这就是让他如此迷人和重要的原因。所以路德确实是这两个冲动来源的地方。当然，他反过来借鉴了奥古斯丁
and ultimately on the Bible. But the framing of it is new. This is what is so thrilling and intoxicating. And it's also very brave because he is also questioning the authority of the papacy. And he has a colleague at Wittenberg who's the professor of law, a guy called Hieronymus Scherf, brilliant name. And Scherf says to Luther, you know, the papacy is not going to stand for this
并最终借鉴了圣经。但这种框架是新的。这就是为什么它如此令人兴奋和陶醉。而且这也非常勇敢，因为他也在质疑教皇的权威。他在维滕贝格有一位同事，是法律教授，一个叫希罗尼穆斯·谢尔夫（Hieronymus Scherf）的家伙，名字很棒。谢尔夫对路德说，你知道，教皇不会容忍这个的。
and Luther doesn't care. So why does Luther not care? I think it is a sense of intellectual excitement, but I think it is also something much, much more really, really profound that is so important and so transformative on the history of Christianity that the moment when he supposedly first experiences it has been called the Reformation moment. And just to put that into context, Tom, the difference between him and the people we're talking about in the modern world is he will die if he gets this wrong. And if he misjudges, he's in real danger for his life. Right. Yes. So I think you have to have an absolute certitude to display that kind of courage.
而路德不在乎。那么路德为什么不在乎呢？我认为这是一种智力上的兴奋，但我认为这还有更深、更深远的东西，这对基督教历史如此重要和具有变革性，以至于他据称第一次体验它的那一刻被称为“宗教改革时刻”。汤姆，为了把这一点放在背景中，他和我们在现代世界谈论的人的区别在于，如果他弄错了，他会死。如果他误判了，他真的有生命危险。对吧。是的。所以我认为你必须有绝对的确定性才能表现出那种勇气。
And it's this reformation moment, I think, that gives Luther that certitude. But whether it is a moment or whether it is a continuous process is much debated. But essentially, we saw in the first episode how Luther becomes a monk and he lives in dread of God's judgment. He says that he hates God. Yeah. You know, God is going to condemn him and there's nothing he can do about it. And so this is why he's, you know, starving himself and praying and confessing for hours on end and all that kind of thing.
我认为正是这个宗教改革时刻给了路德那种确定性。但它是瞬间还是一个持续的过程，争论很大。但本质上，我们在第一集中看到路德是如何成为一名僧侣的，他生活在对上帝审判的恐惧中。他说他恨上帝。是的。你知道，上帝要谴责他，他对此无能为力。所以这就是为什么他，你知道，挨饿、祈祷、忏悔数小时等等。
And then he gets to study the Bible as a professor and to reflect on what it is saying. And the more he does this, so the more he comes to see all his attempt to earn liberation from God's condemnation as wasted effort. And the key figure in this is St. Paul. In the New Testament, there are a number of his letters. They're the earliest texts that we have written by a Christian. And for people who don't know who St. Paul is, Tom, he's a bloke who was persecuting the Christians and then converts on the road to Damascus. Right. So initially, Paul is a Pharisee. So he's very, very learned in the scriptural teachings, in the law, the law that's been given to Moses. But it turns out that this is not what redeems him. What redeems him is this kind of blinding
然后他作为一名教授开始研究圣经，并反思它在说什么。他做得越多，他就越意识到他所有试图赚取上帝谴责的解放的努力都是浪费精力。其中的关键人物是圣保罗。在新约中，有他写的几封信。它们是我们拥有的由基督徒写的最早的文本。汤姆，对于那些不知道圣保罗是谁的人，他是一个曾经迫害基督徒，然后在去大马士革的路上皈依的家伙。对吧。所以最初，保罗是一个法利赛人。所以他在经文教义、律法、摩西给出的律法方面非常、非常有学问。但事实证明，这并不能救赎他。救赎他的是这种盲目的
moment that is summed up in the phrase, the road to Damascus. He has a vision of the risen Christ and is blinded by the descent on him of the spirit. And this marks him out as one of the elect. And Luther, when he is reading Paul, he gets overwhelmed by a similar consciousness of divine grace that God has chosen and loves him. And Luther says of this moment, this feeling of being washed in the love of God, I felt I was altogether born again and had entered paradise itself through open gates. That thing of being born again, so influential. Is Luther the first person to use that particular phrase, being born again? Or is he the person who popularizes it, I should say?
时刻，总结在“去大马士革的路上”这个短语中。他看到了复活的基督的异象，并被降临在他身上的圣灵弄瞎了眼睛。这标志着他是选民之一。路德在读保罗时，被一种类似的神圣恩典意识所淹没，即上帝已经拣选并爱他。路德谈到这一刻，这种被上帝之爱洗礼的感觉时说，我感到我完全重生了，并通过敞开的大门进入了天堂本身。那种重生的事情，太有影响力了。路德是第一个使用“重生”这个特定短语的人吗？或者我应该说，他是普及它的人？
I think he popularizes it. I mean, the idea of being born again is in the Bible. Right. That is what baptism gives you. But I think the idea that you can have this moment and be sure of it. So this is what's new. So Alec Ryrie, who is brilliant on this, on what it is that makes this reformation moment so important. He says that Luther's theology was not a doctrine. It was a love affair. So it's not about drawing abstract theological principles. Right.
我认为是他普及了它。我的意思是，重生的想法在圣经里。对吧。这就是洗礼给你的东西。但我认为你可以有这个时刻并确定它的想法。所以这是新的。所以亚历克·赖里，他在这一点上很出色，关于是什么让这个宗教改革时刻如此重要。他说路德的神学不是一种教义。这是一场恋爱。所以这不是关于得出抽象的神学原则。对吧。
It's about articulating a feeling, a kind of an intensity of love. So all the time that Luther had kind of been dreading that he was unworthy of God's love, that he would be condemned by God's justice, that God hates him. This realization suddenly that God loves him and that God loves him in a way that transcends rubrics of you've done this and therefore you have to pay this penalty and you'll be in purgatory this long. That's not what it's about at all. It's total, it's kind of intoxicating, it's beyond reason. And it comes to Luther, I think, partly through kind of psychological impulses, a kind of yearning for this love in the face of all the unhappiness that he's been feeling in trying to kind of justify himself to God. But as I say, it also comes from reading Paul and particularly one line.
这是关于表达一种感觉，一种爱的强度。所以路德一直担心他不配得到上帝的爱，他会被上帝的正义所谴责，上帝恨他。这种突然意识到上帝爱他，而且上帝以一种超越了“你做了这个，因此你必须支付这个惩罚，你将在炼狱待这么久”的准则的方式爱他的认识。根本不是关于那个。它是完全的，它是某种陶醉，它超越了理性。我认为它部分通过某种心理冲动来到路德那里，一种在面对他试图向上帝证明自己时所感受到的所有不快乐时对这种爱的渴望。但正如我所说，它也来自阅读保罗，特别是其中一行。
So there's a line in the letter that Paul writes to the Christians in the church, the letter to the Romans, the righteous shall live through faith. And Luther understands this to mean the faith specifically that God loves you and that it doesn't matter if you're lost to sin. Everyone is lost to sin. Humanity is so sinful that they can't through their own agency obtain the forgiveness of God, but it doesn't matter because if God loves you, then you exist in a state of grace. And the state of grace is the feeling that you have that Christ is present in you, in your secret most heart. And the certainty of that grace in turn gives you what Luther calls the peace of conscience. That all your anxiety about whether you're going to be redeemed or not is gone. And so you can have a kind of deep, profound, spiritual joy and sense of certitude that essentially cuts the Gordian knot of all the
所以保罗写给教会基督徒的信中有一行，给罗马人的信，“义人必因信得生”。路德理解这意味着上帝爱你，而且如果你迷失在罪中也无关紧要。每个人都迷失在罪中。人类是如此有罪，以至于他们不能通过自己的代理权获得上帝的宽恕，但这无关紧要，因为如果上帝爱你，那么你就存在于恩典状态中。而恩典状态是你所拥有的感觉，即基督存在于你心中，在你最隐秘的心里。那种恩典的确定性反过来给了你路德所说的“良心的平安”。你所有关于你是否会被救赎的焦虑都消失了。所以你可以有一种深刻、深远的属灵喜乐和确定感，这基本上切断了所有
purgatory stuff, all the confession stuff, all the, am I going to go to heaven or not? And it's an incredibly, I mean, it's a really, really kind of profound moment because it provides both a theological, but more importantly, I think an emotional justification for getting rid of all the purgatory and clergy and pilgrimage and all that kind of stuff. And it's not just that that stuff is wrong, it's positively sinful because it's blocking off a proper understanding to the Christian people of God's love. And so this is why Luther emphasizes the loneliness of the individual Christian before God. It is you alone with scripture, with faith. You don't need anything else.
炼狱的东西，所有的忏悔东西，所有的“我会去天堂还是不去？”的东西。这非常，我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常深刻的时刻，因为它提供了神学上的，但我认为更重要的是情感上的理由，来摆脱所有的炼狱、神职人员、朝圣等等。这不仅是那些东西是错的，而且是积极的罪恶，因为它阻碍了基督徒对上帝之爱的正确理解。所以这就是为什么路德强调个人基督徒在上帝面前的孤独。是你一个人，带着经文，带着信仰。你不需要任何其他东西。
Okay, so two things, Tom. Number one, if this is the case, why isn't this just a massive get out for, you know, you don't have to feel bad about your sins and stuff because God loves you. Everyone's sinful. You know what? Everybody is sinful. The world is sinful. And the thing is, all that matters is that God loves you. So crack on, you know, fill your boots. This is the great debate. And this is the great criticism of that kind of Protestant sense of election. I mean, you put your finger on it immediately. Secondly, what I would say, thinking about the 2020s, a criticism that some people would have of the capital E enthusiasm find so obnoxious. Is Luther not conscious that other
好吧，两件事，汤姆。第一，如果是这样的话，为什么这不仅仅是一个巨大的借口，你知道，你不必因为你的罪什么的而感到难过，因为上帝爱你。每个人都有罪。你知道吗？每个人都有罪。世界是有罪的。而重要的是，上帝爱你。所以继续吧，你知道，尽情享受吧。这是伟大的辩论。这是对那种新教选民意识的伟大批评。我的意思是，你立刻指出了这一点。其次，我想说的是，考虑到2020年代，一些人对大写E的狂热感到如此令人反感。路德难道没有意识到其他人
people will find his moral certainty, his sense of being saved? Oh, look at me. God loves me. Isn't that brilliant? No, he doesn't because he's in a love affair. Right. Yeah. He's in a love affair. And when you're in a love affair, you don't care what other people think. You only care about the person you're in love with. I mean, I think that that is it. Yeah. Because of course the institutional criticism would be, it's all about you, isn't it? Right. This is very narcissistic. Well, it is, but it also, I mean, again, I think this is why it matters because it does feed into all kinds of intellectual trends that will emerge over the course of the centuries that follow. So again, to quote Ryrie, the idea's initial impact was like that of Darwinism or Marxism in their own times. It was a concept that no one had thought of in quite those terms before,
会发现他的道德确定性，他那种被拯救的感觉？哦，看我。上帝爱我。那不是很棒吗？不，他没有，因为他正在恋爱。对吧。是的。他正在恋爱。当你恋爱时，你不在乎别人怎么想。你只在乎你所爱的人。我的意思是，我认为就是这样。是的。因为当然，制度上的批评会是，这都是关于你，不是吗？对吧。这非常自恋。好吧，确实如此，但它也，我的意思是，再次，我认为这就是它重要的原因，因为它确实助长了在随后的几个世纪中出现的各种智力趋势。所以再次引用赖里的话，这个想法最初的影响就像达尔文主义或马克思主义在它们自己的时代一样。这是一个没有人以那种方式思考过的概念，
but that seemed to many people once they had grasped it to be self-evidently true. So it's not just Luther. I mean, it's other people as well. Once they have this, then they can share in the love. But of course, it kind of turns on its head, the notion that everyone in Christendom is a Christian. Because what Luther is saying basically is that you have to have this feeling that God loves you, that you've been born again, that you've entered the gates of paradise, or you're not really a Christian. So the implication in turn of that is that only a
但对许多人来说，一旦他们掌握了它，似乎就显而易见是真的。所以这不仅仅是路德。我的意思是，其他人也是如此。一旦他们有了这个，他们就可以分享这种爱。但当然，它颠倒了基督教世界每个人都是基督徒的概念。因为路德基本上是在说，你必须有这种上帝爱你的感觉，你已经重生了，你已经进入了天堂之门，否则你不是真正的基督徒。所以反过来，这意味着只有
tiny elect really are going to be saved. And although Luther does believe that the knowledge of God is imprinted on the soul of every human being, I mean, what he would call belief is the idea that you have an absolute conviction that your salvation has been granted to you. And this, of course, is a much rarer bloom. And so he basically, Luther, ends up saying that maybe only one in a thousand people rank as a Christian, a true Christian. Do you know what he should say that the other people are, Tom?
极少数的选民才会真正得救。虽然路德确实相信上帝的知识印在每个人的灵魂上，我的意思是，他所说的信仰是你有绝对的信念，即你的救赎已经赐给了你。当然，这是一种更罕见的花朵。所以他基本上，路德，最终说也许千分之一的人才算基督徒，真正的基督徒。你知道他应该说其他人是什么吗，汤姆？
I'm very pleased with this. It's very Liz Truss-like behavior. He should call them chinos, Christians in name only. Very good. I do like that. Yeah, excellent. And of course, the implication in turn of that is that, say you live in a Protestant country, you know, a Protestant community, you can't just coast. I mean, you have to work out what you believe. The job of believing becomes something that is personal to you. You can't just leave it to the professional Christians.
我对这个很满意。这非常像特拉斯（Liz Truss）的行为。他应该称他们为“Chinos”，即“名义上的基督徒”（Christians in name only）。非常好。我确实喜欢那个。是的，太棒了。当然，反过来这意味着，假设你生活在一个新教国家，你知道，一个新教社区，你不能只是随波逐流。我的意思是，你必须弄清楚你相信什么。相信的工作变成了一件对你个人来说的事情。你不能只是把它留给职业基督徒。
Yeah. It's about your truth, right? It's about living your truth. Yes, living your truth. This is where the idea of living your truth comes from. And of course, the reason why this breeds, in the long run, atheism and unbelief, as well as belief in God, is that you may just feel the strain is too great. You know, you try to believe and you don't. So again, I think this is why Luther stands at the head of the atheism that emerges in the West. But partly because the atheism is all about
是的。这是关于你的真理，对吧？这是关于活出你的真理。是的，活出你的真理。这就是“活出你的真理”这个想法的来源。当然，它之所以在长期内滋生无神论和不信，以及对上帝的信仰，是因为你可能只是觉得压力太大了。你知道，你试图相信，但你没有。所以再次，我认为这就是为什么路德站在西方出现的无神论的顶端。但部分原因是无神论完全是关于
you again. It's like, what do you think? Exactly. It's ignoring tradition and all that stuff. And so that's why humanists are patently the descendants of Luther. Their truth is that they don't believe, but they don't believe in a very Lutheran way. So that's why I think it really matters. Basically, belief in the sense that we today understand belief is being born here. And because we're so habituated to it, we don't recognize how profound a change it is. Yeah, we don't see it. I mean, the word I would use is individualism. You're basically saying, are you not, that pre-Luther, the idea of religious belief was collective, that you really ought to
又是你。就像是，你怎么看？没错。这是对传统以及所有那些东西的无视。所以这就是为什么人文主义者显然是路德的后裔。他们的真理在于他们不信，但他们以一种非常“路德式”的方式不信。所以我认为这真的很重要。基本上，我们今天所理解的“信仰”这种观念就是在这里诞生的。因为我们对此太习以为常了，以至于我们没有意识到这是一个多么深刻的转变。是的，我们看不出来。我的意思是，我会用的词是“个人主义”。你基本上是在说，不是吗，在路德之前，宗教信仰的概念是集体的，你真的应该
believe and most people what they personally thought didn't occur to them most people because they just assumed you would go along with what everybody else said to most yeah and it's luther who invents the idea or popularizes the idea that your relationship with the world of religion must be a personal one. And so when people say, well, I don't know whether I believe in God, but I have a personal spirituality or whatever. That's Lutheran because before him, no one would have ever thought to say that. Is that right? Yeah. I mean, to go back to the COVID analogy where we were saying that in the pandemic, most people were content to rely on the epidemiologists to basically kind of tell them what to do. Yeah.
去相信，而大多数人根本没想过他们个人怎么想，因为他们只是默认你会随大流，跟着别人说的话走。是的，正是路德发明或普及了这样一种观念：你与宗教世界的关系必须是个人化的。所以当人们说，“嗯，我不知道我是否相信上帝，但我有我个人的灵性”之类的，那是路德式的，因为在他之前，没人会想到这么说。是这样吗？是的。我的意思是，回到新冠疫情的类比，我们当时说在疫情期间，大多数人满足于依赖流行病学家，基本上让他们告诉自己该做什么。是的。
They had no reason to doubt it, to unbelieve what they were saying. Now it's as though, say during COVID, the vaccines will only work on those who absolutely and unshakably believe that they will work. I mean, that's the shift, the change. But also, I guess the idea that if you met with a group of friends, each of them would say, well, I have my own very personal beliefs about COVID. I mean, no one would say that. It'd be a mad thing to say. And so this in the long run is the problem, but Luther doesn't recognise it at this point because he thinks that there is only one way of understanding it. And he frames it, I think, as a single blinding moment, a reformation moment, because in a way that does make it more personal. It does imply that rather than something that he's worked out over a long period of time, it's a single blinding moment of revelation that enables him properly to understand God.
他们没有理由怀疑，没有理由去“不信”他们所说的话。现在就好像，比如在新冠期间，疫苗只对那些绝对且坚定不移地相信它们有效的人才起作用。我的意思是，这就是转变，这就是变化。但我也在想，如果你和一群朋友见面，每个人都会说，“嗯，关于新冠，我有我非常个人的信仰。”我的意思是，没人会这么说。那会是一件疯狂的事情。所以从长远来看，这就是问题所在，但路德在这一点上并没有意识到，因为他认为只有一种理解方式。而且我认为他将其构建为一个单一的、令人目眩的时刻，一个宗教改革的时刻，因为在某种程度上，这确实让它变得更加个人化了。这确实暗示了这并非他经过长时间思考得出的结论，而是一个单一的、令人目眩的启示时刻，使他能够正确地理解上帝。
And then people call it his tower experience, like he was shut up in a tower thinking about it or something. Yeah. So he gives a range of accounts of how he came by this moment later in life so one of them he's he's in the cloaca so the shitter uh and so you know we've talked about this in the previous episode tom if i had a flipping pound for every time you so he's on the toilet right and what he's doing there is that he is appropriating the dimension of the devil i.e excrement and and filth to god okay you know later in life he will say and again you know apologies to people listening but when he avows his faith in christ he says if that is not enough for you you devil addressing satan i have also shat and pissed wipe your mouth on that and take a hearty bite of it you don't hear that from any theologians these days, do you?
然后人们称之为他的“塔楼体验”，就好像他被关在塔里思考这件事一样。是的。所以他后来在生活中给出了关于他如何获得这一时刻的各种说法，其中一个说法是他当时在厕所里，也就是那个“排泄处”。所以你知道，我们在上一集里谈过这个，汤姆，如果我每听你说一次就有一英镑的话……所以他当时在厕所里，对吧？他在那里做的是将魔鬼的维度，即排泄物和污秽，与上帝联系起来。好吧，你知道他晚年时会说——再次向听众道歉——当他宣誓信仰基督时，他说：“如果这对你来说还不够，你这魔鬼”（对着撒旦说话），“我也拉了屎撒了尿，用那个擦擦你的嘴，狠狠地咬上一口。”你现在在任何神学家那里都听不到这种话，对吧？
No. But essentially what he's saying is that even the dimension of Satan, Christ is to be found there. Christ can purify everything. But you're right. The other famous account he gives is that he's in a tower in the monastery at Wittenberg. And do you think he means that metaphorically? It's so debated.
没有。但本质上他是在说，即使在撒旦的维度里，也能找到基督。基督可以净化一切。但你是对的。他给出的另一个著名说法是他当时在维滕贝格修道院的一座塔里。你认为他是隐喻吗？这争议很大。
I don't think we'll ever know. Okay. And I mean, again, he also gives various accounts as to when it happened. So he specifically gives the date of 1519. So that's two years after the 95 theses have gone up. So Richard Rex in his book, I think very convincingly argues that it happened early in 1518. So just after he's put it up. And I think that this is what gives him the courage to do what he does to defy the papacy. Because in summer of 1518 Rome concludes that they are heretical and on the 7th of August news reaches Luther in Wittenberg that he is summoned to Rome and he knows that this is a summons that is likely to end up with him being burnt at the
我想我们永远不会知道。好吧。我的意思是，他对于这件事发生的时间也给出了各种说法。他明确给出的日期是1519年。那是《九十五条论纲》张贴后的两年。所以理查德·雷克斯在他的书中非常有说服力地论证说，这件事发生在1518年初。也就是他张贴论纲之后不久。我认为这正是给了他做他所做之事的勇气，去反抗教皇权。因为在1518年夏天，罗马断定这些论纲是异端，8月7日，消息传到维滕贝格的路德耳中，说他被传唤到罗马，他知道这很可能意味着他最终会被烧死在
stake. Luther is facing certain death or is he? Return after the break to find out what happens to him. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
火刑柱上。路德面临着必死无疑的局面，是吗？休息后回来看看他发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. The papacy, sent the 95 theses by the local archbishop, had pondered them for eight months before finally pronouncing, in August 1518, that they were indeed heretical.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。教皇权在收到当地大主教送来的《九十五条论纲》后，思考了八个月，最终在1518年8月宣布它们确实是异端。
The author had been summoned to Rome, yet this, far from settling the matter, served only to stoke the flames further. Already in Wittenberg, writings by the local inquisitor had been ceremonially burnt in the market square. Cayetan, tracking events from his residence in Augsburg, fretted that the bushfires of controversy were increasingly out of control. As papal legate, it was his urgent responsibility to stamp them out. The best and most Christian way to do this, he decided, was to summon the troublesome author of the 95 Theses to Augsburg and persuade him in person to recant. Austere, learned and devout, Cayetan was a man whom even those normally suspicious of inquisitors knew that they could trust. His invitation was duly accepted. On the 7th of October 15 1518 martin luther arrived in augsburg so this is the moment tom from dan brown
作者被传唤到罗马，但这非但没有平息事态，反而火上浇油。在维滕贝格，当地宗教裁判所写的文章已经在广场上被仪式性地焚烧了。卡耶坦在奥格斯堡的住所追踪着事态发展，他担心争议的野火正越来越失控。作为教皇使节，扑灭这些火苗是他刻不容缓的责任。他决定，最好的、最基督徒的方式就是传唤《九十五条论纲》那位麻烦的作者到奥格斯堡，并亲自说服他撤回言论。卡耶坦严谨、博学且虔诚，即使是那些通常怀疑宗教裁判官的人也知道可以信任他。他的邀请如期被接受。1518年10月7日，马丁·路德抵达奥格斯堡。所以这就是汤姆在丹·布朗
or tom holland's book dominion your own book when luther a man whose writings have been condemned as heretical comes face to face with a prince of the church, an inquisitor. And a cardinal. Yeah. Who has the power over him, does he not? I mean, Luther's life hangs in the balance here. Is that too strong? Yeah.
或者汤姆·霍兰的《支配》一书——你自己的书——中提到的时刻，当路德，一个著作被谴责为异端的人，与一位教会亲王、一位宗教裁判官面对面时。还有一位红衣主教。他对他有生杀大权，不是吗？我的意思是，路德的生命在这里悬于一线。这说法太夸张了吗？是的。
Oh, Tom. Because basically Luther has been given safe passage. Yeah. But yeah, I mean, in the long run, absolutely. I mean, this is incredibly high stakes. And particularly because Cajetan, in so many ways, is the embodiment of everything that Luther is rejecting. So he is someone who's devoted his life to the study of all kind of the philosophy and the medieval understanding of God that Luther is rejecting. But he is absolutely, I mean, he's a very impressive man, very serious,
哦，汤姆。因为基本上路德获得了安全通行证。但是的，我的意思是，从长远来看，绝对是这样。我的意思是，这赌注高得惊人。特别是卡耶坦在许多方面是路德所拒绝的一切的化身。所以他是一个将一生奉献给研究路德所拒绝的那种哲学和中世纪对上帝理解的人。但他绝对是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，非常严肃，
very moral. He's actually head of the Dominicans. And although we've been framing the Dominicans as the baddies in this story, you know, Tetzel is a Dominican. Of course, the Dominicans elsewhere are behaving very well. So we think a friend of the show, Bartolome de las Casas, the Dominican in the new world, who is standing up for the rights of the Indians, as he would call them, out there. And Cayetan is appalled by what he's being told about how the Spanish are behaving in the New World. And he actually meets the Spaniard and he says to him, do you not doubt that your king is in hell?
非常有道德。他实际上是多明我会的领袖。虽然我们一直把多明我会描绘成这个故事里的坏人，你知道，特策尔就是个多明我会修士。当然，其他地方的多明我会成员表现得非常好。所以我们想到节目的朋友，巴托洛梅·德拉斯·卡萨斯，那位在新大陆的多明我会修士，他正在为他所称的“印第安人”的权利挺身而出。卡耶坦对被告知的西班牙人在新大陆的行为感到震惊。他实际上见到了那个西班牙人，并对他说：“你难道不怀疑你的国王在地狱里吗？”
So he's a morally impressive man. He's not one of your corrupt cardinals. He's not a sinister evil cardinal, the kind that poisons a nunnery. And he's an Italian, right? He's from Gaeta, hence the name. Yeah, so hence his name. So his real name is Tommaso de Vio, and he names himself Tommaso after Thomas Aquinas, who is the greatest of the medieval theologians, devotee of Aristotle. And the guy that Luther hates. And the person who Luther particularly hates, absolutely. But as well as being a churchman,
所以他是一个道德上令人印象深刻的人。他不是那种腐败的红衣主教。他不是那种会毒害修女院的阴险邪恶的红衣主教。而且他是意大利人，对吧？他来自加埃塔，所以名字由此而来。是的，所以名字由此而来。所以他的真名是托马索·德·维奥，他以托马斯·阿奎那的名字命名自己，那是中世纪最伟大的神学家，亚里士多德的信徒。也是路德最痛恨的人。也是路德特别痛恨的人，绝对是。但除了作为教会人士，
he's also a very, very skilful diplomat, despite the fact that he goes around insulting the Spanish king. And so he's been sent to Augsburg, not specifically to meet Luther, but to try and coordinate a crusade against the Turks who were starting to really move into the Balkans at this point.
他也是一位非常、非常老练的外交官，尽管他到处侮辱西班牙国王。所以他被派往奥格斯堡，并不是专门为了见路德，而是为了协调一场针对土耳其人的十字军东征，当时土耳其人已经开始真正进入巴尔干半岛了。
So this is fascinating, isn't it? So we talked last time, didn't we? Or a couple of episodes ago about how the Ottomans had captured Constantinople in 1453, an absolutely unbelievably shocking moment for Christendom. So they take Algiers in 1516, they're sort of spreading through the Mediterranean, but they're going to capture Belgrade in 1521.
这太迷人了，不是吗？所以我们上次谈过，不是吗？或者几集前谈过奥斯曼人在1453年占领了君士坦丁堡，这对基督教世界来说是一个令人难以置信的震惊时刻。所以他们在1516年夺取了阿尔及尔，他们正在地中海蔓延，但他们将在1521年占领贝尔格莱德。
Yeah, so they're preparing for a big campaign against Belgrade this very summer. Then they're preparing for a big campaign against Belgrade this very summer. Then they crush Hungary five years later. Yeah. And then by the end of the 1520s, they are going to be at the gates of Vienna. So really within striking distance of Germany. Yeah. And remember that we talked about Johann Hilton, the monk in Eisenberg, where Luther was at school, who, you know, he supposedly wrote
是的，所以他们正在为今年夏天针对贝尔格莱德的大规模战役做准备。然后五年后他们粉碎了匈牙利。是的。到1520年代末，他们将到达维也纳城下。所以真的就在德国的打击范围内了。是的。还记得我们谈到的约翰·希尔顿，路德上学时在艾森伯格的那个修士，他据说用自己的血写下了
prophecies in his own blood. And he had prophesied that Germany would be conquered by the Turks and that this would herald the coming of the apocalypse. Now, Cayetano is absolutely against this. The papacy is not in favor of the idea that the apocalypse is threatening. And in fact, in 1513, a council in the Lateran palace in Rome had specifically prohibited preaching the immanence of the Antichrist. But of course, Luther is all over this, not least because Hilton, this prophetic monk, had foretold that a great prophet would emerge in 1516, which is close enough to 1517 for Luther to think that it might actually be him.
预言。他预言德国将被土耳其人征服，这将预示着世界末日的到来。现在，卡耶坦绝对反对这一点。教皇权并不赞成世界末日即将来临的观点。事实上，1513年罗马拉特兰宫的一次会议专门禁止宣扬“敌基督”的迫近。但当然，路德对此非常热衷，尤其是因为希尔顿这位预言家修士曾预言一位伟大的先知将在1516年出现，这离1517年足够近，让路德认为那可能就是他自己。
Just on that apocalyptic thing, Tom, you and I know, and everyone listening to this knows, that the Ottomans didn't get into Central and Western Europe. Well, they didn't get beyond Hungary. They didn't take Vienna. They didn't get into Germany. But nobody knows that then. I mean, the whole Luther story surely only makes sense if you think that this is a society that thinks it is facing imminent invasion, occupation, the stamping out of Christianity, whatever. There's this incredible sense of existential dread that hangs over the whole story. Yeah. And this really ties Cahiton's hands in dealing with Luther, because we mentioned that the emperor Maximilian is fading and he wants to ensure that his grandson Charles will
关于那个末日论，汤姆，你和我都知道，听这个节目的每个人也都知道，奥斯曼人并没有进入中欧和西欧。好吧，他们没有越过匈牙利。他们没有占领维也纳。他们没有进入德国。但当时没人知道这一点。我的意思是，整个路德的故事只有在你认为这是一个认为自己面临迫在眉睫的入侵、占领、基督教被铲除等威胁的社会时，才说得通。整个故事笼罩着一种令人难以置信的生存恐惧感。是的，这确实束缚了卡耶坦处理路德的手脚，因为我们提到皇帝马克西米利安正在衰老，他想确保他的孙子查理能
succeed him as Emperor and this obviously gives enormous power to Frederick, Luther's defender and protector as an elector. Yeah, because it's not a done deal that a Habsburg will succeed it could be somebody else. No, it's not a done deal. I think the
继位成为皇帝，这显然给了路德的辩护者和保护者弗雷德里克作为选帝侯巨大的权力。是的，因为哈布斯堡家族继位并不是板上钉钉的事，可能是别人。不，这不是板上钉钉的事。我认为
key thing is that Charles wants to be elected unanimously and Frederick is keeping his cards close to his chest and not saying who he is going to vote for. And so that means that Cahitan, if he's to get a kind of united front against the Turks, he can't afford to alienate Frederick. And this is why Frederick is able to persuade Cahitan to meet Luther in Augsburg rather than have him sent to Rome. Again, Luther is very, very lucky about this. So he's lucky, but of course he also has this incredible ability to seize the limelight. And so again, he goes to Augsburg on foot, kind of playing the humble man of God, as opposed to the splendor and pomp of Cahitan as a kind of
关键在于查理希望全票当选，而弗雷德里克守口如瓶，没有说他要投给谁。这意味着卡耶坦如果想建立一个针对土耳其人的统一战线，他就不能得罪弗雷德里克。这就是为什么弗雷德里克能够说服卡耶坦在奥格斯堡会见路德，而不是把他送到罗马。路德在这方面确实非常、非常幸运。所以他很幸运，但当然他也有这种令人难以置信的吸引聚光灯的能力。所以他再次步行前往奥格斯堡，扮演谦卑的上帝之仆，与卡耶坦作为教会亲王的辉煌和排场形成对比。卡耶坦非常温和地欢迎他。他扮演着父亲对儿子说话的角色，试图说服他放弃错误。但他们进行了三次会面，在会面过程中，卡耶坦越来越失控。他变得越来越生气。他的声音越来越高，因为他很快意识到，危及的不是《九十五条论纲》的细节。而是本质上谁在基督教世界拥有权威。对卡耶坦来说，谁拥有权威是不言而喻的。是教会。是天主教会。一直如此。永远如此。我的意思是，质疑这一点简直是不可理喻的。但路德正在质疑这一点。他正在质疑
prince of the church. Ketan welcomes him very gently. He's kind of playing the part of a father speaking to a son, trying to persuade him of the error of his ways. But they have three meetings, and over the course of the meetings, Ketan loses it more and more. He gets more and more cross. His voice goes up higher and higher, because he realizes very, very quickly that what's at stake is not the details of the 95 Theses. It's about essentially who has authority in the Christian world. And to Kertan, it seems self-evident who does. It's the church. It's the Catholic church. It always has done. It always will. I mean, to question that is just unspeakable. But Luther is questioning that. He's questioning
教皇权。他正在质疑教会法。他正在质疑教皇权。他正在质疑教会法。他正在质疑所有源自亚里士多德的哲学，全部。路德主张真正重要的只有圣经，“唯独圣经”。他对卡耶坦说：“教皇不在上帝的话语之上，而是在其之下。”卡耶坦简直不敢相信。他不敢相信自己正在与这个默默无闻的修士争论，而这个修士竟然提出这种观点，并拒绝接受教会教义的威严。所以，用你在播客系列中之前用过的类比，这相当于一位极其杰出的科学家，你知道，世界上最伟大的科学家之一，
the papacy. He's questioning canon law. He's questioning the papacy. He's questioning canon law. He's questioning all the philosophy derived from Aristotle, all of it. And Luther is arguing that all that really matters is the Bible, sola scriptura, scripture alone. And he says to Cahitan, the Pope is not above, but under the word of God. And Cahitan can't believe it. He can't believe that he is arguing with this obscure monk who is making this case and refusing to accept the majesty of the teachings of the church so to use an analogy that you've used previously in the podcast in the series it is the equivalent of an incredibly distinguished scientist you know one of the
突然发现自己必须与一个不仅在地位上远不如他，而且说“我不太相信你的科学”，并将其拆解到地基，说他不接受科学家及其同事认为理所当然的一切的人进行辩论。但我认为区别在于，这个反对教授的人会有基础知识，使他能够争论
world's great scientists, suddenly finding that he's got to have a debate with somebody who not merely doesn't come anywhere near him in eminence, but says, I don't really believe in your science, and is kind of ripping it down to the foundations and saying he doesn't accept everything that the scientist and his colleagues take for granted. But I suppose the difference would be that this person who's opposing the professor would have a basic grounding that would enable him to argue
他的观点，因为路德在说：“反驳我，去查圣经，向我证明教皇应该拥有这个，亚里士多德在那个问题上是对的，等等。”是的。这对他是问题，对吧？那是个问题。卡耶坦回来后说：“是的，但这是教会的威严。这是传统。我体现了它。”路德说：“我的良心对我来说比你说的更重要。”在这里，他为良心进行了辩护，这再次对我认为现代西方人理解他们行为的基础、他们的道德支撑的方式非常重要。但同样，是路德迈出了这一步，并将良心置于最重要的位置，
his case because Luther is saying, you know, disprove me, go to the Bible and prove to me that the Pope should have this and that Aristotle is right on that or whatever. Yeah. And that's a problem for him, right? That is a problem. And Cayetan comes back and says, yes, but this is the majesty of the church. This is tradition. I embody it. And Luther says, my conscience is more important to me than what you're saying. And here he is making the plea for conscience, which again is so important to the way that I think people in the modern West understand the basis for what they do, their moral underpinnings. But again, it is Luther who is taking this step and foregrounding conscience as something
比任何其他东西都重要，真的。所以你可以看出为什么卡耶坦完全发火了，并告诉路德走开。所以，你知道，除非你准备撤回言论，否则别回来，而路德没有。所以发生的事情是，斯陶皮茨，德国奥古斯丁修会的领袖，那个最初让路德成为维滕贝格教授的人，他解除了路德的誓言。这意味着他不再是奥古斯丁修会的一员。
that is more important than anything else, really. And so you can see why Cato completely loses his rag and tells Luther to go away. And so, you know, only come back if you're prepared to recant and Luther isn't. And so what happens is that Staupitz, who is the head of the Augustinians in Germany, the guy who'd originally made Luther a professor at Wittenberg, he releases Luther from his vows. And so that means he's no longer part of the Augustinians.
所以路德现在，你知道，他感到自己孤身一人，但对路德来说，孤身一人是解放。它让你更接近上帝。所以他通过写两封令人难以置信的粗鲁信件来展示他对上帝的爱，一封寄给卡耶坦，一封寄给教皇。然后他翻过奥格斯堡的城墙，溜回了维滕贝格。所以他被踢出了奥古斯丁修会。
And so Luther is now, you know, he feels he's alone, but to be alone for Luther is liberating. It brings you closer to God. And so he displays his love of God by writing two unbelievably rude letters, one that he sends to Cairtown, one to the Pope. And then he clambers over the city walls of Augsburg, and he scarpers back to Wittenberg. So he's been kicked out of the Augustinians.
这实际上发生了什么吗？我认为这是一个双方同意的分离。对。因为斯陶皮茨想，我不需要这种麻烦。你知道，这很尴尬。是的，他不想让他的修会和他个人被拖入正在发生的所有这些事情的混乱中。
Is that effectively what's happened? I think it's been a mutually agreed separation. Right. Because Staupitz thinks, I don't need this hassle. You know, this is embarrassing. Yeah, he doesn't want his order and himself personally to be dragged down into the kind of the magic mix of all this stuff that's going on.
对。我想这对修会的声誉最好，马丁。但是，你知道，这种对机构会怎么想的担忧已经开始看起来非常过时了，因为路德再次在广播他的观点。
Right. I think it would be best for the reputation of the order, Martin. But, you know, already, this kind of concern with what institutions will think is starting to look very retro because Luther, again, is broadcasting his perspective.
对。而且因为它更有趣，它得到了更多的关注。所以他回到维滕贝格，写下了他与卡耶坦相遇的经过。他说：“上天乐于让我成为人们谈论的话题。”这真是极好的“凡尔赛”。当然，卡耶坦，他不会广播他所做的事情的记录。所以路德就像一个拥有大量
Right. And because it's more interesting, it gets far more attention. So he gets back to Wittenberg and he writes up an account of his encounter with Cayetan. And he says, it has pleased heaven that I should become the talk of the people. Which is tremendous, humble bragging. And of course, Cayetan, he's not going to broadcast an account of what he did. So Luther is like someone who has masses of
社交媒体账号的人。而卡耶坦就像一个连电子邮件地址都没有的人。这意味着路德可以主导辩论的条款。但你把路德比作乔丹·彼得森。当然，乔丹·彼得森引发了巨大的反弹。我的意思是，他并没有一切都如愿以偿。他不断地受到辱骂。所以同样的事情开始发生在路德身上，路德并不是唯一能够使用印刷机的人。还有其他人。还有其他人有这种场合感。其中之一是路德的前同事、朋友，一个叫约翰·埃克的人。埃克对路德的方向感到震惊，并挑战他进行辩论。这又非常21世纪，不是吗？是的，这就是现在发生的事情。理查德·道金斯与一位主教见面，或者
social media accounts. And Cayetan is like someone who doesn't even have an email address. And it means that Luther can dominate the terms of the debate. But you compared Luther to Jordan Peterson. Of course, Jordan Peterson provokes massive counter-reaction. I mean, he doesn't have it all his own way. He's endlessly being abused. And so the same thing starts to happen to Luther, that Luther is not the only person who is able to use the printing press. There are other people as well. There are other people with a sense of occasion. And one of them is a former colleague, a friend of Luther's, a man called Johann Eck. And Eck is appalled by where Luther is going and challenges him to a debate. And again, this is very 21st century, isn't it? Yeah, that is what happened now. Richard Dawkins meeting with a bishop or
出现在乔·罗根的节目上之类的。是的，绝对是。就是那种事。埃克挑战路德进行辩论。路德同意了，他将与维滕贝格大学校长卡尔施塔特一起去，卡尔施塔特正支持路德。实际上他最终比路德更激进，不是吗？他被路德的信息弄得太兴奋了。是的，他确实。他确实。我们稍后会谈到。路德接受了去莱比锡的邀请，但这被证明是一个严重的错误。所以就像如果你作为一名流行病学家被邀请上乔·罗根的节目去辩论一个对疫苗持怀疑态度的人。是的。你知道，你注定要失败，因为场地会对你不利。
appearing on the Joe Rogan show or something like that. Yeah, absolutely. It's that kind of thing. And Eck challenges Luther to a debate. Luther agrees and he'll go with Karlstadt, the chancellor of Wittenberg University, who's kind of rallying behind Luther. And actually ends up being more radical than Luther, doesn't he? He gets so excited by Luther's message. Yeah, he does. He does. We'll come to that. And Luther accepts the invitation to go to Leipzig, but this turns out to be a bad mistake. So rather like if you're invited on Joe Rogan as an epidemiologist to debate someone who is skeptical of faxes. Yeah. You know, you're on a hiding to nothing because the venue will be against you.
莱比锡是另一个萨克森，不是吗？公爵萨克森，不是选帝侯。所以这确实是敌对领土。是的。而且乔治公爵非常虔诚地信奉天主教，对路德非常敌视。是的。所以这对路德来说是不友好的领土。路德到了那里，他很愤怒，因为莱比锡的人民给了埃克一件非常
And Leipzig is the other Saxony, isn't it? Duke or Saxony, not electoral. So it genuinely is rival territory. Yes. And the Duke Georg is very devoutly Catholic and very hostile to Luther. Yeah. So it's unfriendly territory for Luther. And Luther gets there and he's furious because the people of Leipzig have given Eck a very
华丽的外套和长袍，而他们没有给他一件。所以他为此大发雷霆。埃克是一位非常好的辩论者，非常擅长宣传自己。他能够让路德公开承认一系列令人震惊的异端邪说。他让路德公开记录在案，说教皇的权威没有圣经的制裁，炼狱也没有，1414年在火刑柱上被烧死的布拉格异端扬·胡斯在各种问题上都是对的。是的，那太震撼了，不是吗？斯科特·亨德里克斯，我想，在他的路德传记中说，路德实际上说，胡斯的许多信仰完全是基督徒的。这就像是说，
fancy coat and gown and they haven't given him one. So he's in an enormous strop about this. And Eck is a very good debater and very good at publicising himself. He is able to get Luther publicly to confess to a whole staggering array of heresies. He gets Luther to go publicly on record as saying that the authority of the Pope does not have the sanction of scripture, that purgatory doesn't, that Jan Hus, the Prague heretic who had been burnt at the stake in 1414 had been right on all kinds of issues. Yeah, that's massive, isn't it? Scott Hendricks, I think, in his book on Luther says, Luther actually says, many of Hus' beliefs were completely Christian. And that's like saying,
以诺是对的。你知道，不是吗？我的意思是，这有点像是在正统派眼中玷污自己，无可救药。是的。而且这是在正统派眼中无可救药。是的。而且这是那种可能发生的事情，比如在推特争吵中，人们可能会变得如此愤怒，以至于最终说出他们真正后悔的话。是的。所以卡尔施塔特实际上，他把善行，比如施舍之类的，比作“经血污秽”。是的，那非常强烈，这又是，你知道，那不是你想在推特上看到的东西，关于善行
Enoch was right. You know, isn't it? I mean, it's sort of, it's tainting yourself in the eyes of the Orthodox beyond redemption. Yeah. And it is the eyes of the orthodox beyond redemption. Yeah. And it is the kind of thing that can happen, say, on a Twitter spat, that people can get so cross that they end up saying things that they really come to regret. Yes. So Karlstadt actually, he compares good works, so giving alms or whatever, to menstrual filth. Yeah, that's very strong which again is you know that's not the kind of thing that you want to have on your twitter feed and on a good works
我们不能马上陷入那个问题，因为那是一个非常大的问题，但那是日常虔诚的很大一部分，不是吗？你被期望做一系列的事情，比如在这里捐点钱，在那里捐赠一个礼拜堂。你知道，对很多人来说，那就是他们宗教生活的本质。这就像是公开地表现得善良，但基本上是用钱。不是吗？嗯，只是给乞丐钱，然后你被告知，嗯，这是经血污秽。是的，好吧，汤姆。
we can't massively get bogged down on that right away because that's a very big issue but that is a huge part of kind of everyday piety isn't it that that you are expected to do a whole range of like give a bit of money here, endow a chantry there. You know, to a lot of people, that is the essence of their religious life. It's like being kind publicly, but with money, basically. Isn't it? Well, just giving money to a beggar and you're being told, well, this is menstrual filth. Yeah, okay, Tom.
当你这样说的时候，我会感到被冒犯，换个说法。所以这基本上就是为什么人们普遍认为路德和卡尔施塔特输了。对。但从长远来看，这并不重要，因为辩论中实际说了什么并不重要，重要的是它是如何呈现的。虽然埃克非常擅长辩论，虽然他确实理解自我宣传的重要性，你知道，他根本无法与路德相比，基本上，我的意思是，埃克的名声被路德和
When you put it like that, I'd be offended, put it that way. So this is basically why it's generally accepted that Luther and Karlstadt have lost. Right. But in the long run, this doesn't matter because it's not what's actually said in the debate that counts, but how it is presented. And although Eck is very good at debating, and although he does understand the importance of self-publicity you know he's nowhere compared to luther and basically i mean x reputation gets annihilated by luther and by
他的追随者摧毁了。所以他被讽刺为讲师、酒鬼，关于他的讽刺作品被出版，显示他骑在一只山羊上，然后被淋上屎，他被描绘成雇佣了一个女巫，他最终被阉割了。他最终被阉割了。他最终被阉割了，没错。得了吧，汤姆，我知道它要来了。他们发布卡通片显示他是一头猪，他只是变成了一个仪式性的公共对象，就像今天某人在
his followers so he gets satirized as a lecture as a drunkard kind of satires on him are published that show him flying on a goat that then gets showered in shit he's shown as employing a witch he ends up being castrated He ends up being castrated. He ends up being castrated, exactly. Come on, Tom, I knew it was coming. They issue cartoons showing him as a pig and he just becomes a kind of public object of ritual in the way that someone being monstered
社交媒体上被攻击一样。埃克真的是，你知道，他是现代社交媒体的第一个受害者，你可以这么说。对。琳达·罗珀说他的胜利最终并不重要，因为它不有趣。而路德的运动很有趣，吸引了人们的注意。好吧，这很令人兴奋，因为再次，他现在全力以赴，每周，
on social media might be today. And Eck is really the, you know, he's the first victim of modern social media, you might say. Right. And Linda Roper says of his victory that it ultimately doesn't matter because it was not interesting. Whereas Luther's campaign was interesting and caught people's attention. Well, it is thrilling because again, he's now going full tilt and week after week,
他都提出越来越精彩的异端邪说，令人震惊、令人兴奋的异端邪说。他能做到这一点基本上是因为他现在不再是修士了。他不受修道院常规的束缚。所以他可以把所有时间都花在相当于电脑的东西上，发出各种信息和东西。实际上，就像某人醒来，上推特，辱骂别人，回复辱骂，他花了很多时间回复那些辱骂他的人。所以他非常像特朗普。他为他的敌人发明绰号。所以埃克是那个“傻瓜”，
he's coming out with ever more brilliant kind of heresies, shocking, thrilling heresies. And he can do this basically because now he's no longer a monk. He's not bound to the monastic routine. So he can just spend his whole time on the equivalent of a computer, firing out kind of messages and things. And actually, like someone waking up, going on Twitter, abusing people, replying to abuse, he spends a lot of his time replying to people who are sending him abuse. And so he's very kind of Trumpian. He invents nicknames for his enemies. So Eck is that fool,
教皇是那个“狼”。但他也在写一系列精彩的论文。我想他觉得，你知道，“做一天和尚撞一天钟”，我全力以赴。所以到这个时候，他认为仅仅改革教会是不够的。整个东西都必须被推倒。他开始广播这个信息，他正在以一种前所未有的方式主导话语。所以亚历克·赖里给出了这个令人难以置信的统计数据，在1520年代，路德负责了德国印刷厂出版的小册子总产量的五分之一以上。而在1519年的这个时候，甚至更多，因为其他人没有赶上他。
the Pope, that wolf. But he's also writing a series of brilliant treatises. And I think he's feeling, you know, I might as well hang for a sheep as a lamb. I'm going full in. And so by this point, he's thinking that it's not enough just to reform the church. The whole thing has just got to be pulled down. And he starts to broadcast this message and he is dominating the discourse in a way that no one had ever done before. So Alec Ryrie gives this incredible statistic that over the course of the 1520s, Luther was responsible for over a fifth of the entire output of pamphlets by German presses. And at this point in 1519, it's even more because other people aren't catching up with him.
所以这基本上是对他的对手进行饱和轰炸。当路德在1520年12月10日收到那份教皇绝罚令时，关于天主教会，他几乎没有没攻击过的地方。所以他攻击了神职人员独身制，因为没有圣经制裁。他说教皇禁止这个的权力，就像他禁止吃、喝、长胖或肠道自然运动一样。又是肠道。汤姆，你和马丁·路德都对这个问题着迷。我只是着迷于……和马丁·路德都对这个问题着迷。我只是着迷于它们，因为路德是，说实话。他攻击圣徒崇拜。
So it's basically saturation bombing of his opponents. And by the time that Luther gets that bull, that papal bull of excommunication on the 10th of December, 1520, there is very little about the Catholic church that he has not gone for. So he has attacked priestly celibacy because there's no scriptural sanction for it. And he says the Pope has little power to command this as he has to forbid eating, drinking, growing fat, or the natural movement of the bowels. Bowels again. Tom, both of you and Martin Luther are obsessed with this issue. I'm only obsessed by and Martin Luther are obsessed with this issue. I'm only obsessed by them because Luther is, to be fair. He attacks the cult of the saints.
他攻击朝圣。他攻击为死者弥撒。他写了一篇关于“教会的巴比伦囚虏”的论文，公开将教皇与敌基督等同起来。他的一个对手，一个叫托马斯·默纳的人，对此感到震惊，以至于他决定在路德之前直接将其翻译成德语并发布，认为路德会被他自己的话所谴责。每个人都只是说，“太棒了。这太精彩了。”路德不可避免地给了默纳一个侮辱性的名字。所以德语里的“Mer”是“喵”，就像猫一样。而“Ner”是“白痴”。这非常特朗普，不是吗？
He attacks pilgrimages. He attacks masses for the dead. He writes a treatise on the Babylonian captivity of the church that openly identifies the Pope with Antichrist. An opponent of his, a guy called Thomas Myrna, is so appalled by this that he decides to translate it directly into German before Luther can and put it out thinking that Luther will be condemned in his own words. And everyone just goes, brilliant. It's fantastic. And Luther inevitably gives Merner an abusive name. So Mer in German is meow, so like a cat. And Ner is idiot. That's very Trumpian, isn't it?
是的，所以他叫他“喵白痴”。他继续拒绝11世纪改革的这个基础思想，即神职人员和俗人是分开的。他说，不，根本不是。所以他用非常令人难忘的方式表达了这一点。“基督徒是万物完全自由的主人，不从属于任何人。基督徒是万物完全尽责的仆人，从属于所有人。”这就是要瓦解神职人员和俗人之间的传统界限。他基本上剥离了一切，说这必须只是关于耶稣的圣经内容。
Yeah, so he calls him meow idiot. And he goes on to reject this foundational idea of the 11th century Reformation, the idea that clergy and laity are separate. And he says, no, not at all. So he phrases it very memorably. Christian man is a perfectly free lord of all and subject to none. A Christian is a perfectly dutiful servant of all, subject to all. And that is to dissolve the traditional boundaries between clergy and laity. He's basically stripping everything away and saying it's just got to be what's in the Bible about Jesus.
所以引用一下，念珠、朝圣、圣徒崇拜、弥撒、僧侣制度。这里面没有关于基督的东西。人们应该只信任耶稣基督一人。所以换句话说，整个附属品。整个那一套。汤姆，这还有另一个方面。所以他写的东西之一，他那一年写了三部大作，不是吗？其中之一是《巴比伦囚虏》，但另一部是《致德意志民族基督教贵族公开书》。而那后来被视为德国民族主义发展中的关键文本，尽管这个概念对路德时代的人来说毫无意义。
So just to quote, rosaries, pilgrimages, the worship of saints, masses, monkery. There was nothing here about Christ. People should trust in nothing but Jesus Christ alone. So in other words, the whole paraphernalia. The whole shebang. There's one other aspect to this, Tom. So one of the things he writes, he writes three big works, doesn't he, that year. One of them is the Babylonian captivity, but another one is the address to the Christian ability of the German nation. And that later on is seen as a key text in the development of German nationalism, even though the concept makes no sense for somebody in Luther's day.
你认为有一种非常、非常早期的原始民族主义吗？一种对阿尔卑斯山那边意大利外国教长的怨恨，带着他所有的红衣主教，而我们诚实的德国人被踢来踢去太久了？有一点那种感觉吗？绝对有。路德真的感受到了他的德国性，这是他不喜欢教皇权的一部分。好吧。而且有一种对意大利人的敌意。这有点像英国对欧盟的敌意。
Do you think there is a very, very early kind of proto-nationalism, a sort of resentment of the foreign prelate over the Alps in Italy with all his cardinals and we honest Germans have been kicked around for too long? Is there a bit of that? Definitely. Luther really feels his German-ness and it's part of what he dislikes about the papacy. Okay. And there is a hostility towards Italians. It's a bit like hostility to the EU in Britain.
对。就是那种事。布鲁塞尔的官僚，外国人，谁在乎他们说什么。梵蒂冈的官僚对我们指手画脚，是的，那种事，是的，因为扬·胡斯在波希米亚用捷克语写作时也有一点那种感觉，不是吗？有一种非常早期的敏感性，所以再次，我的意思是，这令人陶醉，所以这也是助长路德支持率的混合因素的一部分，对吧？你知道，不喜欢外国人的机会总是很棒的，你知道，爱死它了，这对人们来说总是很有趣。所以我认为这就是为什么，你知道，不仅仅是在维滕贝格，教皇绝罚令被视为蔑视。
Right. It's that kind of thing. Brussels bureaucrats, foreigners, who cares what they say. Vatican bureaucrats pushing us around yeah that kind of thing yeah because that was there a little bit with jan hus writing in czech in bohemia wasn't it there's a sort of very early sensibility and so again i mean this is intoxicating so this is also part of the mix that is fueling support for luther right you know the opportunity to dislike foreigners is always splendid you know love it it's always kind of fun for people to enjoy that. And so I think that that's why when, you know, it's not just in Wittenberg that the papal bull is treated with contempt.
所以即使在莱比锡，你知道，那场辩论发生过，路德并没有给自己增光，绝罚令也被撕成碎片，涂上了，我们称之为排泄物。好吧。你知道，宗教改革非常、非常具有排泄物色彩。我以为你会再次提到那个，但你实际上，你忍住了，这和你很不一样。埃克出去试图张贴它，一群孩子只是把它扯了下来。对。
So even in Leipzig where, you know, that debate had happened and Luther hadn't covered himself in glory, the bull is ripped to shreds and smeared with, let's call it excrement. Okay. You know, the Reformation is very, very excremental. I wondered if you were going to go there again, but you actually, you held back, very unlike you. And Eck goes out and tries to post it, and a whole gang of children just pull it down. Right.
他们都跟着埃克到处走，唱着关于他的侮辱性歌曲。50名学生从维滕贝格赶来，他们追赶他并辱骂他。这是一种字面意义上的“怪物化”。整个德国都为此着火了，但路德根本没有脱离险境。如果德国着火了，风险在于路德本人可能很快也会字面意义上着火。是的，非常好，因为在1521年1月3日，他被正式绝罚，现在的问题是这意味着什么，所有的目光现在都转向了皇帝，他不再是马克西米利安，因为
And they all follow Eck around, singing abusive songs about him. And a gang of 50 students comes from Wittenberg and they chase him and abuse him. It's a kind of literal monstering. The whole of Germany is on fire with this, but Luther is not out of the woods at all. If Germany's on fire, the risk is that Luther himself may soon literally be on fire yes very good because on the 3rd of january 1521 he is formally excommunicated and the question now is what does that mean and all eyes now turn to the figure of the emperor who is no longer maximilian because
到这个时候他已经死了，他的孙子，一个叫查理的笨拙少年，确实继位了。所以他现在以查理五世的身份统治。现在的问题是，查理五世会做什么？天哪。多么悬念。这就是我们将在下一集探讨的内容。所以多么悬念。
by this point he is dead and his grandson who's a rather gawky teenager called Charles, has indeed succeeded him. So he's now ruling as Charles V. And the question now is, what will Charles V do? Crikey. What a cliffhanger. And that is what we will look at in our next episode. So what a cliffhanger.
查理五世，新皇帝，他后来成为欧洲历史上最壮观的人物之一，拥有一个自罗马时代以来从未见过的庞大帝国。我的意思是，甚至比罗马人还大，因为他现在也有了新大陆。有了南美洲。是的。
Charles V, the new emperor, who goes on to become one of the most spectacular figures in European history with a vast empire, the like of which had not been seen since the days of the Romans. I mean, even bigger than the Romans, because he's got the new world now as well. Got South America. Yeah.
所以查理五世，他必须决定如何处理路德。舞台已经为这场令人难以置信的对抗搭建好了，我们称之为“沃尔姆斯会议”，这个名字一直让几代学童感到高兴。所以如果你们是我们自己的修会——“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，人们会因为没听到我这么说而感到失望。如果你们是我们自己的修会——“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，你们实际上可以马上听到关于沃尔姆斯会议的内容。它实际上是我们自己的“饮食”（Diet），不是吗？因为“Diet”是一种……它是一个谈话场所，这基本上就是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的本质，以一种非常
So Charles V, he has to decide what to do with Luther. The stage is set for this unbelievable confrontation, which we know as the Diet of Worms, a name that has always delighted generations of schoolchildren. So people would be disappointed not to hear me say that if you're a member of our own order of friars, the Restless History Club, say that if you're a member of our own order of friars um the rest is history club you can actually hear about the diet of firms right away it's a diet of our own actually isn't it because a diet is a kind of it's a talking shop which is basically what the rest is history club is in a really
可爱的方式。是的，你得到了很多好处，其中之一就是听汤姆没完没了地谈论马丁·路德。如果你不是会员，运气不好。你只能等到下一集发布，正如制片人所说的那样。我不会，但他们会。带着那个重磅炸弹，汤姆，太有趣了。非常感谢。再见，大家。
lovely way yeah you get loads of benefits one of them is to listen to tom talk about martin luther for hours and hours on end if you you're not a member, bad luck. You'll just have to wait till the next episode drop, as the producers call it. I wouldn't, but they do. And on that bombshell, Tom, so interesting. Thank you very much. Goodbye, everybody.
再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。
Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
和提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。